There are four major learning goals for this class. First, you'll learn about
the core methods of knowledge-based AI. These methods include schemes for
structured knowledge representation, methods for memory organization,
methods for reasoning, methods for learning, [UNKNOWN] architectures as well as
methods for meta reasoning. Meta reasoning is reasoning about reasoning. Second,
you learn about some of the common tasks addressed by knowledge-based AI,
such as classification, understanding, planning, explanation, diagnosis,
and design. Third, you will learn ways AI agents can use these
methods to address these tasks. Fourth, you learn the relationship between
the knowledge-based AI cognitive science. Using theories of
human cognition to inspire their design of human level, human-like AI and
using AI techniques to generate testable hypothesis about human cognition.